we scoured the city for the hottest food
fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we got turf set white-eyed Tabata yoga
and bootcamp
it's your body I'm Amanda and I live
Yoga this is your at-home yoga warm-up
hi amenda they just threw me in a room
and said you're gonna do some yoga with
Amanda today so she's got a warm-up
session for us it's a great warm-up
whether it's a running or a CrossFit or
whatever it is what does this consist of
we're gonna do three Sun Salutations
so that's your warmup and I will show
you exactly what that looks like
thank you let's step to the top of your
mat you'll inhale reach your arms up
exhale fold forward hook up to a flat
back jumper step back lower halfway come
into your upward facing dog
pull it back to a downward facing dog
hold here and breathe spreading wide
through your fingers reaching your heels
down hips up to the sky
so you're stretching out the backs of
the legs then you look to the front of
your mat lightly put your first step and
start the whole process over again okay
let's give it a shot so starting at the
top of your mat you're gonna bring your
toes together heels slightly apart so
standing in Mountain Pose
shoulders back chest lifts and then drop
your tailbone inhale reach your arms up
to the sky big breath in exhale fold
forward hinge at your hips inhale look
up to a flat back jumper step back to
your plank pose soft elbows lower
halfway bend the elbows straight
backwards inhale come up
upward facing dog roll over the tops of
your feet roll the shoulders back pull
yourself back to a downward facing dog
hips high nice breathe here reaching
your heels down separate the feet
yeah just to touch they keep reaching
heels down look to the front of your
mats off the knees jumper set the arms
up and then hands come back to heart
center
that is your warmup that's that's pretty
good I feel I feel light but in a good
way yeah it's kind of a cool feeling
so to recap you inhale reach up exhale
fold forward inhale look up the flat
back jump or step back to your
chaturanga position pull through to
upward facing dog exhale back to
downward facing dog jump to the front of
the mat and repeat that three times
which gives you your complete yoga
warm-up I feel like you could almost do
this for anything else it's a great
warm-up for any discipline that you do
good to know all right so thank you guys
thank you Amanda for showing me this
this warm-up you guys want to find out
more about Amanda and some yoga stuff
you can find out about her at Amanda
Murdoch comm make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes